that's why I think women should get
larger sentences because their time is
awesome it is way better to get their
hair braided they got a girlfriend at
summer camp they're finding ways to put
on nail polish there's no nail polish in
jail they're making nail polish out of
[ __ ] crayons or something like that
men are making knives out of soapbox so
they can protect themselves from getting
busted in the shower you can't compare
three to three it's not three to three
it's like that wage gap or whatever it
is yeah same thing with prison it should
be like ten to three if you're a girl
you get 10 years so every three years
that a guy does because I'm sure it's
like three times less dangerous it's
like a woman's size so if Meg was guilty
she should have got 50 years in jail
instead of if Tory was guilty getting 20
or whatever whatever that is whatever
the math adds up I actually believe that
yeah exactly I'll be honest if you go to
one of those like cute guys
that should be longer too you could do
one and buff or you could go 10 in
Country Club